the movie starts with the introduction
of a man who has been eating chicken all
his life but one day he comes across a
horrible truth a woman serves him some
chicken and since the man is extremely
hungry he eats it without any questions
and spits out the bones but as he stares
at the bones he notices some patterns so
he tries to assemble them together
shockingly the bones make up a human
hand and its shape looks eerily familiar
when the man stares for a while he
notices that the middle finger is
slightly bent just like that of his son
it appears as if the man has eaten his
own son's hand oh boy been there the
man's name is Mark and he is the CEO of
a large Company Mark has a very
successful career now but when he was a
child he was often beaten up by his
violent father therefore since Mark
established his own company he has never
again visited his hometown in Kentucky
but one day when he gets the news that
his father has died he becomes slightly
upset Mark hated his father and he
doesn't want to go back to his hometown
but when his wife via Aura suggests they
all visit Kentucky to pay their final
respects he reluctantly agrees the next
day the couple and their two children
samsara and Titan fly to Appalachia
Kentucky on a small private plane Mark
himself flies the plane showing that he
has come a long way since he escaped his
abusive father on the way to their
destination the family stops at a gas
station to refuel when Mark goes inside
the store he notices some mysterious
things like human skulls preserved
animals and insects for sale most likely
for black magic this reminds Mark of his
dark and ignorant childhood so he rolls
his eyes and walks up to the counter
with a bag of chips there he notices the
store owner sewing a Mojo bag curious he
asks the store owner about it and the
latter replies that Mojo bags can
protect someone from Black Magic he also
suggests the family takes some with them
but Mark being an atheist dismisses the
theory as Superstition and leaves the
family then continued to their final
destination and when Mark asks his
children about the trip so far they
insult the place making fun of the local
black people this and fear viora and she
gets into a verbal argument with Mark
viora feels that Mark enables their
behavior by not disciplining them
however Mark quickly responds that he
will never be like his abusive black
father after a while it suddenly begins
to Reign causing the plane to shudder
violently Mark tries his best to get
them out of the situation but the winds
are so strong that he eventually loses
control and crashes the screen then
blacks out and Mark wakes up later with
bruises all over his body in an
unfamiliar room he takes a look around
and realizes that he is in the Attic of
someone's Farmhouse suddenly the
homeowner Miss Eloise appears and tries
to get him back on the bed but Mark
resists and asks her about his family
Miss Eloise who is very strict and
particular about everything quickly
calls up her husband Earl and their
giant son Lewis the three of them then
try to calm mark down but when he tries
to run away Lewis picks him up and
throws him on the bed like a rag doll
after this Earl informs Mark that his
plane crashed yesterday and that he was
alone expectedly Mark refuses to believe
that and continues to insist on finding
his family he again tries to escape but
just then miss Eloise blows a strange
powder over his face which makes him
fall asleep this implies that the family
is not an ordinary one and they possess
some magical powers either that or
ketamine later miss Eloise is seen
making Mark's voodoo doll which she
refers to as a Boogity doll she explains
that she wants to nurse mark back to
health using this doll after finishing
up she places the Boogity doll by the
window and secures the window with a
white powder to keep the devil away
after she leaves Mark starts looking for
a way to escape he realizes that the
door is locked so he sneaks out of the
window and onto the roof he then jumps
from one roof to another as it rains
heavily he eventually reaches the barn
where Miss Eloise has gathered with
several other villagers here it is
revealed that Miss Eloise Is A Healer
who uses her Voodoo powers to cure
people of their sickness after a while
the ceremony commences and Earl informs
everyone that today his wife Miss Eloise
is going to use Anna parts for her root
work but on the day of the blood moon
she is going to do something much bigger
then the treatment begins Earl cuts a
cat's tongue and puts it in Miss
Eloise's mute patience Boogity doll she
then reads some spells and shockingly
the mute patient starts speaking as the
crowd erupts in cheers Mark watches it
all unfold from a large peephole on the
roof following this Eloise moves on to
her blind patient named Julius she
places a goat size in julius's eye
sockets and begins chanting some spells
lo and behold Julius regains his
eyesight and immediately points at Mark
who is peeking from the roof terrified
Mark quickly Docks but miss Eloise and
her family rushed to the attic to
inspect they eventually find him inside
the room but notice the open window and
Mark's soaking wet body Miss Eloise can
tell that he had stepped out of his room
however she lets it slide and asks him
what he thought of her abilities
expectedly Mark doesn't believe in her
methods and instead he compares her to
his superstitious father he feels that
her treatments are psychosomatic which
is theory that if somebody believes in
something desperately it will physically
become true Ms Eloise is offended and
she poignantly retorts that people from
her Village believe in these treatments
because they don't have access to Good
Health Care Plus those goat's eyes
obviously did the trick she then locks
the window and door before leaving him
alone the next day Mark wakes up to find
a plate full of meat he enjoys the dish
prepared by Miss Eloise before
apologizing to her for being rude the
other day she forgives him and goes to
the kitchen to fetch Mark another plate
leaving the attic door open taking
advantage of the opportunity Mark
quickly takes out the Bell attached to
the door so that it doesn't make noise
when he tries to escape after he
finishes the food Miss Eloise brings out
some bones explaining that they can tell
one's future she claims that these bones
are telling her that on the day of the
blood moon Mark will get all the poison
out of his body and meet his family she
then instructs him to throw the bones on
the bed to learn more about his future
however he refuses to participate and
Miss Eloise comments that Mark is just
like her son Lewis before she got him
straight 8 after Miss Eloise leaves him
with the bones Mark becomes bored and
starts assembling them but to his horror
he realizes that it's a human hand
moreover it appears to be his son
Titan's hand as it too has a broken
middle finger because of the Revelation
a terrified Mark throws up everything he
consumed he then uses his lock picking
skills to unlock the door and sneak out
of the room with his injured feet Mark
drags himself downstairs but before he
can escape Miss Eloise's pet Crow alerts
her prompting him to hide she rushes to
the attic to check up on her prisoner
but by that time Mark has already
escaped to the house he runs into the
woods and comes across the debris of the
crashed plane inside he sees the blood
of his family but no dead bodies Mark
then notices a Hut nearby but before he
can investigate he collapses on the
ground from exhaustion the next day he
again wakes up and Miss Eloise's attic
and notices her leaving for the market
with Earl from the window Mark then
removes the dressing from his feet and
to his horror he finds a metal Spike
shoved there by missile Eloise to keep
him from healing and running away with
no other choice he summons all his
strength and courage to pull the nail
out he also tries his best to keep
himself from screaming so that no one
can sense his Escape after the painful
ordeal Mark again Ventures out and
notices three newly filled Graves
fearing they could belong to his wife
and children he frantically digs the
grave but it turns out that they're just
the graves of sacrificed animals
relieved Mark heads to the barn where he
finds a basement upon inspection he
comes across some of Miss Eloise's dark
magic books and desecrated dead bodies
he goes through her books and learns
that she is preparing him for the blood
moon day for the transference of Life
spell for this spell a person's life is
sacrificed to mend someone else's
injuries although Mark is terrified he
soon regains his composure and turns the
tables by using the magic books to make
a new Boogity doll for Miss Eloise
shortly after as he proceeds to return
back to the room he hears the sound of a
phone ringing and after some searching
eventually finds it Mark then takes the
phone back back to his room but forgets
to close the main door when Miss Eloise
returns she notices the door and
suspects that Mark has managed to get
out once again she immediately orders
Lewis to fetch the ax and rushes to the
attic Mark hears the approaching
footsteps so he reluctantly puts the
spike back in his foot which makes him
wail in pain after a while the Voodoo
Woman arrives fortunately after
inspecting his dressing she doesn't find
anything suspicious so she lets him be
after she leaves Mark calls 9-1-1 and a
local policeman picks it up surprisingly
the cop reveals that his family came to
the police station a week ago and
reported him and Titan missing Mark
controls his emotions and tells the
officer that he has been held hostage by
a certain Miss Eloise and Earl the
policeman recognizes the couple and
Promises to get there as soon as
possible a while later he arrives
Outside The Farmhouse and talks to miss
Eloise while Mark removes the spike from
his foot again unfortunately this only
enrages the woman so she storms into the
attic to punish Mark she grabs his
Boogity doll and slams him on the bed
after this she makes him lose his voice
and wraps a threat around to the Boogity
effectively tying the real mark up after
she leaves to meet the officer Mark hops
to the window but he is unable to utter
a word and alert the cop refusing to
give up Mark grabs the Boogity doll and
hops downstairs but by then the
policeman has already laughed despite
this he slowly follows the cop and
eventually catches up to him after
putting a thread in the boogity's mouth
Mark also gets his voice back he then
explains everything to the cop and asks
him to drive away but just when they
reach a bit further Mark realizes that
the cop is friends with the voodoo
couple and he has again taken him back
to the doomed house it's a blood moon
and Marcus then dragged into the barn
where the villagers have gathered to
witness his sacrifice viora simsara and
Titan are also brought into the barn
much to Mark's shock on one hand he is
relieved to see Titan and the rest of
his family alive but they are unusually
calm and quiet seemingly under Miss
Eloise's spell after the ceremony begins
Miss Eloise blows her magic dust on Mark
making him fall asleep he is then laid
on the table as the villagers cheer with
excitement Miss Eloise plans to replace
Earl's diseased heart with marks so she
proceeds to make an incision on his
chest with a dagger but suddenly Mark
wakes up takes out the spike from his
foot and stabs Earl right through the
heart much to everyone's horror he then
gets up from the table causing all the
people including Miss Eloise to run out
in fear it turns out Mark had earlier
replaced Miss Eloise's magic dust with
something else and therefore it didn't
work after the coast is clear Mark
approaches his family and uses the
original magic dust on them they soon
come back to their real selves but Mark
is devastated to learn that Titan's hand
has really been amputated next Mark
ambushes the policeman and steals his
car however instead of leaving with his
family he returns to the barn meanwhile
Miss Eloise and the other villagers
return with the giant Lewis and the
latter storms into the barn to kill mark
the two engage in a brutal fight but
Lewis easily gets the upper hand but
suddenly starts gasping for air and
pukes a lot of water before dropping
dead to everyone's astonishment Mark had
drowned Lewis's Boogity doll Furious
Miss Eloise screams and confronts him
she admits that he was smart for
drowning Lewis's Boogity doll but he
can't do the same to her as she has
hidden hers really well she then
proceeds to stab him but Mark blows the
magic dust over her face causing her to
freeze instantly surprisingly he brings
out her Boogity doll that he had made
earlier and hammers it sending the real
Miss Eloise flying the old woman's body
knocks over a wooden pillar and the barn
catches fire before leaving Mark places
some white powder on the door which can
supposedly keep the evil out and since
Miss Eloise is no less than a devil
herself she fails to cross the line
hence trapping her inside the fire the
other locals quickly confront Mark but
he threatens to use their Boogity dolls
and makes them Retreat as the fire
engulfs the barn Mark returns to his
family and together they drive away from
the village the movie ends as Miss
Eloise's original Boogity doll shown in
the basement which appears to be
completely fine I don't quite understand
the point of the racism at the beginning
of this movie but otherwise that was
awesome subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching